Hi!
Nicht wundern, dass ich in diesem Keller hier bin
Ich baue heute etwas
Bestimmt seht ihr's schon im Titel
Das Video heute dreht sich um dieses tolle Produkt
Ich möchte heute Versuchen Bilou zu sprengen
Wenn wir hier mal ganz genau schauen:
Wir machen heute genau das Gegenteil
Aber damit meine Kamera nicht kaputt geht muss ich erstmal einen kleinen Kasten bauen
in dem die Explosion stattfinden wird
Ich hab vor das ganze zu machen indem ich einfach eine ganze Menge Grillanzünder
dadrunter lege, dann baut sich Druck in der Flasche auf und sie explodiert.
Ich würde sagen: die Idee ist so bescheuert, dass sie nur gut werden kann.
Fangen wir an den Kasten zu bauen!
DATADAM, YIAAA
So Leute, die Wände sind gebaut, jetzt bau' ich nurnoch vorne die Plexiglasscheibe dran
Das wir auch was sehen können
Und dann kann's los gehen!
So Leute, ich hab' jetzt alles fertig gemacht, ich hab' die Innenseite noch mit Alufolie ausgekleidet
Damit das Holz kein Feuer fängt - hoffentlich.
Ich hab wirklich SO lange daran gesessen jetzt
Falls ihr das auf irgendeiner Ebene feiert, dieses Video - lasst mir dafür schonmal ein Like da
Also ich hab' das hier jetzt auf ein massives Metallstück gesetzt
Und jetzt pack' ich die Grillanzüner rein, und dann kann's auch schon los gehen!
Ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt, aber ich glaub' es wird lustig
Ich tu' es wirklich.
Das ist mit Abstand das doofste Video das ich gemacht habe und wahrscheinlich das doofste das ich jemals machen werde
Aber: Ich hab' jetzt angefangen und dann werd' ich's auch zu Ende bringen
Zur kleinen Erklärung: Ich hab' sowas früher immer mit meinen Schulfreunden gemacht
Das sind wir in der sechsten Klasse oder so irgendwo in den Wald gegangen und haben die Dinger, also
Deoflaschen damals gesprengt, und jetzt mach' ich das mit Bilou
Ich glaube die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen sollten ganz vernünftig sein, und ich hoffe vor allem das nicht
irgendwie das Plexiglas vorne zerbricht und mein Handy dann drauf geht
Weil das will ich relativ nah filmen lassen wenn's explodiert
Es ist übelst dumm, aber ich mach' das jetzt einfach!
Für die Wissenschaft!
Bibi, falls du dieses Video siehst:
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich das getan habe, aber wir werden jetzt sehen ob dein Duschschaum explodiert -
oder nicht.
WTF
Das hat geklappt! Oh mein Gott!